envoyez vos enfants jouer dehors
mais surtout les scellés s'amuser seul
c'est le conseil que participaction de
nos parents canadiens
le port a reproché aux cow parade est
trop par à mai ce qu'on a constaté c'est
qu'effectivement les jeunes sont plus
actifs
lorsqu'ils sont en situation des
libertés par rapport à 2 par an les
statistiques ne trompent pas les jeunes
ne font pas assez d'exercice à peine 14
% des enfants de 5 à 11 ans font au
moins une heure d'activité physique par
jour et seulement 5% des 12 à 17 ans or
des questions à l'extérieur les enfants
sont deux fois plus actifs que
lorsqu'ils font du sport à l'intérieur
le problème aujourd'hui on voit de moins
en moins d'enfants jouets d'or et encore
moins en l'absence d'un adulte
en tant que parent c'est normal on veut
protéger nos enfants mais ça on se
réflète havlat bleus 30 ans ou est ce
qu'on dit les enfants et podcasts la fin
grimper ils ont enfin bougé les enfants
les parents étaient pas des réalisations
aujourd'hui on en a eu deux on les suit
partout qu'il faut comprendre c'est
quand les empêchant de boucher justement
on se retrouve avec des enfants qui sont
plus sur internet sur leur ipad sur leur
jeu vidéo qui vaut moins jouer dehors
piqué au moindre bobo mais c'est normal
les recherches ont également démontré
que les enfants qui jouent fréquemment à
l'extérieur développe plus d'habileté
motrice sociales et comportementales que
ceux qui passent beaucoup de temps
l'intérieur c'est d'ailleurs exactement
pour ça qu'on a créé les aires de jeu
estime cette spécialiste
c'est vraiment l'endroit dans la société
où les enfants ont droit de vérifier ils
ont droit de sauter en guise ont droit
de descendre la tête par un beau ils ont
droit de tourner il on doit degré paix
parce qu'on sait que cet endroit l'eau
n'y a pas de véritable danger
quant au parrain qui évoque les
problèmes de sécurité
rappelons que selon la grc les
probabilités pour un petit canadien de
se faire enlever par un inconnu sont de
une sur 14 millions ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal